Además este vídeo de cerca de tres
minutos el presidente Joe biden también
publicó un comunicado en el que anuncia
que su jefa de campaña será Julie Chávez
Rodríguez ella fue asesora de Barack
Obama y es asesora en este momento de la
Casa Blanca ella liderará entonces la
campaña a la reelección lanza su campaña
la reelección el mismo día que la lanzó
Hace cuatro años cuando dijo que quería
precisamente recuperar la el alma de
este país se centran las libertades
individuales de las mujeres con su
derecho al aborto de la comunidad lgtbi
con su derecho a el matrimonio
igualitario que está en riesgo en muchos
estados y en el derecho al voto que se
está está en peligro también para muchas
minorías en algunos estados del sur hay
que Resaltar también que en las
encuestas el presidente Joe biden pues
no no arrojó números muy positivos en
cuanto a el interés de los mismos
demócratas de reelegirlo Sin embargo lo
que dicen muchos es que no hay en el
partido demócrata una figura
suficientemente fuerte para ser
contrincante de Donald Trump y poder
contrarrestar La amenaza del extremismo
en Estados Unidos